افاد مصدر تركي رسمي للجزيره ان تركيا
اعطت مهله زمنيه محدده للجانبين الامريكي
والروسي لاخراج قوات سوريا ديمقراطيه من
منبج وتل رفعت عين العرب وقال المصدر ان
انقر ابلغت الجانبين الروسي والامريكي ان
الموله الزمنيه لن تمدد وان البديل سيكون
عمليه عسكريه ضد القوات الكرديه من جهتها
دعت واشنطن لاعاده هيكله قوه سوريا
ديمقراطيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات اي طبيعه للاشتراطات
التي تطرحها كل من انقره وموسكو واشنطن
للتراجع عن العمليه العسكريه التركيه
شماليه سوريا ما هي المده الزمنيه التي
ضربها جانب التركي واكد انها لن تمدد وما
هي السيناريوهات المحتمله التي قد تترتب
على التعامل معها وكيف ستنعكس هذه
التطورات على مسار الازمه وعلى مختلفه
الاطراف والملفات المتشابكه بينها ولا
سيما الحرف اوكرانيا والوجود الايرانيه في
الشمال السوري
[موسيقى]
على انظار كل من واشنطن احاله انقره
شروطها لقاء العدول عن القيام بعمليه
عسكريه بريه في الشمال السوري يتعلق الامر
بانسحاب للوحدات الكرديه من بعض المدن ضمن
مسافه لا تقل عن 30 كلم وكذلك من مواقع
منشات النفطيه يرى الاتراك انها تمثل
شريان امداد ماليا سخي لتلك الوحدات فوقها
هذا وذاك مهله زمنيه لا سبيل لتمديدها
والا فان البديل هو التحرك العسكري
والميداني حزم تركي تتحسب روسيا في ما
يبدو لعواقده من خلال وساطه بين نظام دمشق
وقوات سوريا ديموقراطيه لاجل التوسل
لتفهمات تقطع على توهر البريه التركيه
طريقه فيما تراه واشنطن على ترويجه صيغه
معدله من تلك القوات الجانب الامريكي
اقترح بحسب افاده المصدر التركي للجزيره
اع هيكله قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ومنح دور
اكبر للمكون العربيه في اداره من بجوتا
لرفعه وعين العرب وفقا للمصدر فان تركيا
اشترطت انهاء سيطره قوات سوريا ديموقراطيه
على المنشات النفطيه قبل النظر في
المقترحات الامريكيه اضاف المصدر ان
الجانب الروسي وضع شروطا تتعلق بالملف
الاوكراني مقابل تقديم تنازلات ميدانيه
وسياسيه في سوريا وقال المصدر ان روسيا
عارضت رفع الغطاء عن منطقه الشهباء في ريف
حلب وعين العرب لتسهيل دخول القوات
التركيه اليهما
الجيش التركي جدد في الاثناء قصفه
بالمدفعيه والطائرات المسيره مواقع ما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه شمال شرقي
سوريا وذكرت المصادر ان القصف طال تجمعات
ومراكز في قرن بمحيطه الابيض بريف الرقه
وريف عين العرب على الحدود مع تركيا اضافه
لريف الحسد
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول رسول
توصل النائب السابق في حزب العداله
والتنميه من موسكو ضيفنا هو الدكتور
نيكولاي سوركوف الخبير في المجلس الروسي
للعلاقات الدوليه ومن ولايه نورس كارولا
معنى السفير الامريكي السابق لدى تركيا
مرحبا
عدم تمديد المهله المعطاه لكل من موسكو
واشنطن لحل هذه الازمه وايضا اشتراك
انسحاب القوات الكرديه من المواقع النفط
المنشات النفطيه ما الحسابات التركيه لفرد
هذين الامر
الحسابات التركيه هي تعود الى الامن
القومي التركي بدايه وثانيا
التطهير في المنطقه ونطقها سلاسل كيلومتر
على طول الحدود من العناصر الاتفاقيه عفوا
من العناصر
الارهابيه همم التزاما في الاتفاقيه التي
اجرمت بين الولايات المتحده فروسيا حيث
الطرفان لما يلز- لم يلتزم
بالاتفاقيه وكانت الهجمات الارهابيه تهدد
الامن القوميه التركيه فلذلك تركيا تطلب
شيئا واحدا ان همم تنفذ
اتفاقيه
وتسحب العناصر الارهابيه
ليست مطالب
كده لدى الطرف التركي الجديد الان الحديث
عن اشتراط انسحاب القوات الكرديه من
المنشات النفطيه لماذا
نقول القوات الكرديه لان تركيا ليست لها
اي مشكله مع الاكراد انما القوات
الارهابيه لماذا لان تركيا تلتزم بالسياده
الوطنيه السوريه
القوات او التنظيم الارهابي ما يسمى اسد
هذا تنظيم ارهابي امتداد لتنظيم الارهابي
تحتل ثلث الاراضي السوريه في حمايه
الولايات المتحده فلذلك المطلب في الحقيقه
همم ياتي الى الطرف الامريكي فليس
التنظيمات الارهابيه لان التنظيمات
الارهابيه لا تستطيع
اي نعم المنشات النفطيه ايضا في في داخل
الاراضي المحتله التي
تحتلها الولايات المتحده مع التنظيمه
للارهابي
ولماذا تريد تضع انقره شرطا الان من بين
شروطها انسحاب هذه القوات قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه ما تعرف بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه من هذه المنشات هذا هو سؤالي
نعم هذه القوات
قسد ما يسمون ليست قوات شرعيه انما هذه
عناصر ارهابيه تركيا تكافح الارهاب فلذلك
لا تعترف في قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وتعتبر تركيا هذه القوات هي العناصر
الارهابيه امتداد لتنظيم فكك الارهابي
لذلك موقف تركيا تجاه لتنظيمات الارهابيه
همم سيد روبرت بيرسل السفير الامريكي
السابق لدى تركيا ضيفه
كيف ستعامل الولايات المتحده الان مع هذه
الشروط التركيه الجديده كما ذكرنا عدم
تمديد المهله الالتزام بالمهله الزمنيه
لحل هذا الامر
واشتراك انسحاب هذه القوات ما تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من المنشات النفطيه في
السوري
في الصحافه الامريكيه او من مؤسسات
امريكيه بعد لي هذا المهل الزمنيه التي
اعطتها تركيا اعتقد انه من المثير الاتيما
ان ذلك اتى من مصدر غير معروف
وهذا تكتيك استخدمته تركيا من قبل
تحركات الدبلوماسيه
التي تمني النفس بها من اجل ايضا ان تكسب
الراي العام الداخلي ومن اجل ايضا ان تضغط
على الجهه المختلفه من اجل تقديمها هذه
التناسلات في الحقيقه فان تحديد مهله
زمنيه يعني انا دبلوماسيه التركيه حتى
الان لم تنجح هو ان مواقف الولايات
المتحده وروسيا لم تتغير اذن سيكون علي
انا انتظر المزيد من الردود الرسميه
الامريكيه اذا حول هذا النقطه واعتقد ان
هذا يحصل الان من اجل كسب الراي العام
الداخلي التركي
همم وفقه متابعتك وبمعرفتك
وكيفيه تفكير المسؤولين في داخل الاداره
الامريكيه حياه لهذا الملف باعتقادك كيف
يمكن ان يتم التعامل مع هذه الشروط
التركيه
الشروط التركيه اعتقد ان تحرك هو من اجل
كسر الراي العام التركي
والتحضير لانتخابات السنه المقبله حيث ان
الحكومه ليس لديها شعبيه كبيره بسبب
البطاله والتضخم واعتقد ان
اعلان
تكون سريه هي محاوله لكسب الراي العام
الداخلي يجب ان ننتظر واشنطن همم سيد همم
سيد نيكولاي سور كوفا من موسكو الى اي مدى
يشكل هذا الامر هذا الموقف من جانب
السلطات التركيه ضغطا على
موسكو من اجل محاوله التوصل الى وساطه
سريعه
جدا
فيما يتعلق بالازمه في اوكرانيا
روسيا من قبل ان كانت على علاقه طيبه مع
الاكراد السؤال في سوريا وروسيا تدعم دمشق
وسلامه
والاستقلاليه توسعاده الدوله
يطرحون تحدي الاكبر امام الحكومه وبالتالي
روسيا سوف تدعم الحكومه التركيه ولكن سوف
لن تدعم اي تحركات عسكريه تركيا مكثفه ضد
اكراد هنا تكمن المعادله لان روسيا عليها
ان ترسيا توازن وسوف
عسكري ولكن روسيا سوف ترحب به اي ضعف قد
يحصل لي الاداره الكرديه في شمال الشرقي
حاليا ما تقوم به روسيا هوساطه بين قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه من جهه والنظام السوري
من جهه اخرى من اجل محاوله ترتيب الامور
في تلك المنطقه بحيث تقطع الطريق على اي
توغل بري همم تركي باعتقادك اين وصلت
زي الوساطه وكم من الوقت يمكن ان تستغرق
حتى تصل الى نتيجه
سنوات وبدون ان تحقيق الكثير من النجاح
لان الاكراد يرفضون قبول باي شروط وكذلك
الان انا اعتقد انه تحت الضغط
تدبوده اريل
جيوش الى الحدود لكنني لست اكيد ان هذا
سوف يرضي الحكومه التركيه
وتحاول ان تقنع الاكراد ان هذا افضل حال
لهم في الوضع الحالي
لان الحاله البديل الوحيد هو توهل تركي
مستعد وبوضوح لاتخاذ اجراءات صار مع ضده
قوه ردمقراطيه رسول الله
السلطات التركيه انه لا تمديد للمهله ماذا
يعني هذا بالنسبه للسقف الزمنيه الذي تضعه
لهذه المهله اين متى يمكن ان تنتهي هذه
المهله
والله في الحقيقه ليست لدينا ايه معلومه
عن المهله عن مده المهله لكن هناك
بيان ان الطرف التركي اعطت مهله للترفين
الروسي والامريكي لسحب العناصر الارهابيه
من ام ثلاث نجومتر والا ستقوموا تركيا في
عمليه عسكريه بريه لا محاله ولا مفر منها
لكن المده اا ايضا انا ليست عندي ايه
معلومه ما هي المده لكن المهم هو تركيا
اذا التزمت همم ذات المتحده وروسيا
بالاتفاقيه التي ابرمها تركيا لا تحتاج
الى عمليه عسكريه لكن اذا استمرت العناصر
اسابيع
هل هذا مقبول من تركيا
وان كان يوما واحدا يكفي للانسحاب العناصر
الارهابيه ثلاثين كيلو متر فهذا شيء سهل
جدا
المهم الذي يعني نحن او تركيا تهتم به
الموقف الامريكي لان الولايات المتحده وان
كانت حليفه لتركيا في الحلف الاطلسي الا
انها ليست صديقه لتركيا مواقفها ضد تركيا
للاسف الشديد همم في حمايه الارهابيين
ليست فقط ال- تنظمي الارهابي فكك او قصيده
انما الولايات المتحده تحمي كذلك تنظيم
فتره الارهابي الذي قام بمحاوله انقلابيه
فاشله دبابيه فلذلك الخلاف بين تركيا
والولايات المتحده عميقه عريضه جدا
وضيوفنا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردو انطرح
اشاره مهمه تخص شروط انقره المتعلقه
بالشمال السوري وبالوحدات الكرديه النشيطه
هناك اردوغان قال قاصدا الوحدات الكرديه
المسلحه اذا كان الارهاب ينبع من شمال
سوريا فاننا لن نبعدهم عن حدودنا الى
الداخل فقط بل سنقضي على منابعهم بشكل
كامل اردوغان قال ان بلاده مستمر في
مواجهه التهديدات في سوريا موضحا نحن
مستمرون في اتخاذ اي اجراءات احترازيه
ضروريه في ادلب وكباني اعود اعود الى سيد
روبرت همم
سيد روبرت اذا ضيفنا من تركيا السيد رسول
الله
تركيا لا يحتاج الى فتره زمنيه طويله
لتحقيقه وقد يحصل الانسحاب في يوم واحد ما
رايك
طيب
المهله الزمنيه هي مؤشر الى ان تركيا تخطط
للاشتياح اكثر منهم محاولتها لتوسل الى حل
وهي تحاول كسب الراي العام حتى يبدو ان
الولايات المتحده وروسيا لا تحاولين حلل
مساله بطريقه
تركيا
الولايات المتحده تتحالف مع مكون يهاجم
الاراضي التركيه وبالتالي همم تريد من
الولايات المتحده ان تتخذ موقفا واضحا من
هذا الامر اين المشكله في هذا في هذا
الامر لماذا تعتبره سيد بيترسان انه موقف
يعني في اطار المزايده الانتخابيه
الداخليه
هناك
حرب فحصال في شمال وشرق وربما الان في
جنوب تركيا وهي قد هددت
في اتجاه اليونان
داخل اراضيها بما يساعدها كما تعمل في
الانتخابات العمل الموقف الامريكي بالنسبه
الى شمال شرق سوريا
الحلفاء في سوريا هو الذي منع تنظيم
الدوله من ان يصير منظمه ارهابيه عالميه
هذا المشروع الان في خطر لان المقاتلين
يبتعدون عن
المخيمات ولهذا فان دي فلوماسيه
والمفاوضات ضروريه وليس مها الزمالك
كيف ترى موضوع المهله الزمنيه متى
باعتقادك يمكن الحسم بانور نجحت في
استبعاد همم توغل عسكري تركي ام اخفقت ذلك
ورور
على هذا الموضوع ولكن
من طاقه امنه على طول الحدود
او اسبوعين لانه سوف يتطلب اعاده توزيع
ولكن ايضا الجيش السوري
بعض القوات مع انني لا اعتقد ان عدد
قواتها كافن في المنطقه ولكن باي حال
خلقنا المنطقه الامنه سيستغرق بعد الوقت
ربما اسبوعين الى شهر
ولكن قبل ذلك قد
نجد او قد نرى عمليه محدوده لان الرئيس
موضوع انشاء هذه المنطقه هل هذا مقبول
بالنسبه لتركيا
هذا يعني لست تعرف عنها شيء
بغض النظر اما يتطرق اليه لضيفك الكريم من
من الولايات المتحده تركيا يعني نعم بعد
سته شهور هناك انتخابات رئاسيه ونيابيه
لكن بغض النظر عن الانتخابات السؤال الذي
يكره نفسه لماذا تتواجد الولايات المتحده
في شمال سوريه لماذا
وفي العام في عهد الرئيس السابق ترامب
واعلن ان داعش قد انتهى قد قضينا على داعش
انما هذه زريعه للاسف الشديد للبلايات
المتحده المعروف ان هناك مشروع صحي صحي
يعني بمصايه اسرائيليه وامريكيه
في العمليات العسكريه الثلاثه الماضيه
افسدت هذا المكسوره والان جاء دوره
ثانيه
ولضيفنا من ولايه كارولا
الامريكيه السابق لدى تركيا
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج هيما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]